we saw his [ __ ] up movie last night I
like it though
[ __ ] was cheat that was like to like
like it just the shittiest movie of all
time
HG Lewis [ __ ] right yeah I mean that
dude was just going out of his way to be
as outrageous as possible it's called
blood sucking freaks yeah that was that
was a title they ended up going with I
think he had other titles before there
was about this dude who's kind of like
this real sadist kind of like a
sadomasochist and he's got this lair
it's like a theater and he's got all
these female slaves that he's keeping
him down in a dungeon and they're
cannibalistic cuz he's kind of starving
him and then he's bringing him up and
torturing him in front of a crowd and
the crowd thinks it's all just an act
that it smells like a critic there
that's going I would never review this
this is [ __ ]
I thinks it's fake which pisses off the
dude who runs the place so he has that
guy [ __ ] captured and then man it's
just [ __ ] it's it's like it's it's
like something marquita Saba bleedin it
is actually not that bad it's just that
some of the [ __ ] he came up with you
know there's like something that got a
bit like a marquis de sade writings yeah
an execution of it didn't look realistic
at all and like pulling girls teeth out
and they're just going wow
there's nothing but nudity through the
whole thing so many titties you guys yes
like Oh like wall-to-wall titties yeah
just [ __ ] crazy and all the girls
evidently you know Joe Bob and he had a
guest who's that fresh Jericho yeah
Chris Jericho's on last drive-in by the
way yeah it's all shudder you guys gotta
see it it's pretty good it's a clay it's
a trash classic yeah like if you're into
like trashy horror movie should probably
say I laughed through the whole [ __ ]
thing man I couldn't believe what I was
saying I just couldn't believe it it's
gotta it's got a dwarf in there that
looks like [ __ ] little oats they
called him little oats and oats from
Holland
that's a Chris Jericho yeah all of yous
calling tiny oats or yeah very small
oats or something like and all these
people in this movie are like from the
local theater school that's nearby or
you're saying it was more porn stars
yeah yeah and some of them with
actresses were also porn stars at the
same time they get into that you know
like Chris Jericho and and and and Joe
Bob you know they're talking about
people from the time the girls from that
time you didn't have to really say much
to him to give him take the clothes off
they didn't think it was a big deal they
were all like that so I think this movie
came out in the seventies not for yeah
or 71 I can't remember any agreements or
anything they're just good you take your
clothes off this for this book oh yeah
and then they were talking about all the
orgies that they would have arranged do
you know what I mean is it's a pretty
good show and I'll let Joe Bob and
[ __ ] he's entertaining hosts yeah
it's I got him watching my class driving
cuz I would have liked I said I want I
would only watch it sporadically because
they used to just give him like a
marathon like every holiday or whatever
but now it seems like shudders to given
him like a weekly show which is cool so
he either does one movie or he does a
double feature I guess it's a good show
like they break him up into like single
movies so I'm kind of like you know
behind on a bunch of the episodes they
got this girl she's some kind of
podcaster who's always on there she
helps him out yeah Darcy the male girl
yeah and like you see her and she's kind
of looks good-looking striking but then
the longer you look at her man you she's
funny-looking she's good well she's had
a lot of fun he's had a lot of plastic
surgery makes you wonder like what did
she look like before yeah no I would
like to see what she looked like before
she must have been unrecognizable
because nothing about her face looks
real yeah nothing she's a foot she's a
cool chick though she um she started as
a horror blogger I think I'd have to
like look that up but she would writes a
lot about horror know that Russian girl
that tried to look like Barbie yeah he
looks like that she does look a little
to me she looks like that wait yeah sit
here in the body modification that's
fine she's in don't you could tell yeah
she's in the body mods and all kinds of
so you know that guess it's just a look
that she wanted but you know it's just
weird I think it's weird I'm not used to
seeing it yeah like I was used to it cuz
I've seen her before cuz I watched that
like on several occasions but it's just
I hadn't got
around cuz he did [ __ ] he's done castle
freak I kinda want to watch his version
of castle freak because because he like
talked so much about the movies in
between it's like even if you've seen
the movie before you know he comes up
with leaves like everything about the
[ __ ] like he was when we were watching
blood sucking freak last night he was
talking about the woman that was in it
like the main woman and he was talking
about like all the horrible [ __ ] that
happened to the people that were in the
movie like he's like it's almost like
the movie was cursed or something cuz a
bunch of them like died really young
several of them from liver failure
because they were all about to drunk
yeah this is like New York theater scene
and like people that weren't poor like
shitty be nothing the drugs and stuff is
just like all drugs and they were big
heavy drinkers other drugs a hell of a
drug yeah nice drugs remember that night
said oh he's gonna take credit for that
drug that's a good one but I know I have
to do that [ __ ] are you already good cuz
you know coke needs to have a drug what
was just drunk it's true yeah but yeah
so a bunch of a Mike died in their 30s
and [ __ ] like that and the main woman
that was in it he was like telling a
funny story about I guess they were I
guess it was at the wrap party and he
was talking about how back in the day
like in New York City like among that
you know scene they always like every
party he always had like what they
called the Freak room and that's what
that's where all the cocaine was and
that's where you went like to just to do
whatever and apparently this woman that
was in this was like she was like
engaged to some guy or whatever I Rod
Stewart yeah who looked like Rod Stewart
that's right yeah and and he wet he
couldn't find her like at some point the
party so he goes looking for and he's
she's up in the freak where I'm having
sex with the dwarf that was in this
movie yes don't cook yeah the dwarf
ended up being a porn star later on even
though I'm stealing his [ __ ] thunder
instead of you see instead of
commercials they go to Joe Bob and he
gives a commentary and tells you about
the movie and it's so much better than
having somebody voicing over the program
as you're watching it but I still like
commercial breaks yeah I don't want to
watch commercials I'd rather hear him
because his commentary Nizar just as
good if
better than the movie it makes the well
yeah it does so you know what's going on
because then when you see [ __ ] happen
you laugh because you now have the the
back story yeah because he's I mean like
I said Joe bob has been doing this for
[ __ ] ever I mean I remember seeing
him on monster vision back and T on TNT
that was like back in the [ __ ] 80s or
90s I don't remember and I know he's
been on TV like a long time before that
so he's like a font of knowledge about
shitty horror movies I mean he knows
everything about the [ __ ] he's always
like at conventions and stuff so it's
like all the [ __ ] stories he's got he
just knows everything about the stuffin
yeah great
and he goes [ __ ] on cough hard
r-rated on you now because because we're
on shudders so I can tell you this what
they were doing into orgies and funny
because a lot of people don't don't
really understand what that what well
it's coming it's now come to light in
with the advent of the internet what
[ __ ] entertain all this you are like
all the crazy
yeah you know I mean they might seem
real [ __ ] straightedge and serious so
when they're doing their job but when
they're not working they're doing
something I mean I have to say though
that the 70s were a special time yes
especially yeah and like when when he
was telling like all the stories about
like the behind the scenes [ __ ] and like
the cast of this movie and like what
else they did and stuff I was just all I
could do is just shake my head ago oh
the 70s cuz I mean I was a kid but I
still remember like a lot of the [ __ ]
that was going on around that time
period yeah 80s was kind of like
conservative compared to the 70s well
probably that's why probably because the
70s just went wildly out of control
anybody's like alright we need to rein
that but it was like some crazy yeah
it's like it's funny because I had seen
like a bunch of the you know kind of
schlock classics you know you're early
like splatter flicks like HG Lewis is
like Color Me blood red and blood feast
and all that but for some reason I had
never got around to seeing blood sucking
freaks yeah you guys see it and there's
like some really fun stuff in there you
know you got to see it it's good really
fun the dude who's kind of acting like
that this the guy who's running the
sadomasochistic theatres kind of like a
cross between kind of like a british
anton lavey mixed with marquis de sade
he's just it's just and then he's got
his little dwarf and they said he just
see it and he's all in man he is yeah
the hell out of this yeah it's super fun
sir do is carry yeah and the acting is
it bad
not really I guess a lot of them were
that they could act and they could sing
yeah it's just that they're they're not
dealing with much of a budget and they
didn't really know how to shoot a
slasher slash gore moot movie real well
yeah like they should have done some
different stuff with the camera angles
because they were there's a part where
they're trying to stretch this nude
woman apart like I'm back on a ride and
they're trying to get you to believe
that she's stretched out as far as she
could go and it's obvious she's not
stressed as yes you basically just like
shapes yeah but like they put his leg up
but they haven't BDSM dungeons yeah and
a head a zoomed in on her so you
couldn't really see see what was
happening the angle then it would have
been a lot more effective maybe through
sound effects they could have made
that's what I was saying it's like they
should have used sound if they did like
they didn't think about it yes I guess
but it's like yeah it was just like
funny to see because it's like she puts
her is like man if that if that's enough
to kill you would all be in trouble any
time you try to do jumping jacks or
stuff like that he would just like
spontaneous Lee yeah and they do all
come on it's a gruesome [ __ ] I mean it's
[ __ ] gruesome [ __ ] but because it's
so unbelievable you just go you laughs
yeah you know because this is
preposterous yeah yeah no the the guest
[ __ ] Jericho said had Rob Zombie
filled this I wouldn't go to watch it
yeah terrifying yeah but because they're
filming it you're just kind of laughing
it off yes like the idea of the ideas
[ __ ] up right um you know like way
ahead of its time really because I was
like wow that's creative but um just the
execution of it is so bad I can't like
take it seriously because it doesn't
look real or anything yeah it and and
the people aren't really struggling
struggling or begging for their for
their lives which that's what really
what happened yeah so it ends up just
being kind of like humor
it's kind of its kind of just humor I
think that's what makes it funny it's
kind of funny yeah it's just because you
know people getting fingers chopped off
like eyeball scooped out and eaten and
all this other kind of stuff and they're
not really the reaction like you'd stub
your toe it's like oh my eyeball uh what
it is i watch the [ __ ] and I was gone
there's a certain scene and I went yeah
and I said I said what's that
serial-killer I mentioned [ __ ] which
one was s as I bet you he's seen this
movie oh yeah buddy yeah yeah I've got
Ted Bundy see oh yeah because that's
probably got the idea I do like having
sex with a [ __ ] in the head and cuz that
happens in this movie although it's kind
of like it's just it's implied then yeah
I was watching this movie and I was
thinking you know how kind of like
serial killers didn't they they did
don't have much depth of personality the
kind of robotic yeah well the people in
this movie are kind of robotic the
victims are kind of robotic because they
just didn't and it made me think I think
this is the way serial killers imagine
that their crimes are gonna be like oh I
wonder I think I think this is how they
see it yeah maybe so and it's just kind
of fun and games and it's not really
because they can't like there's no
connection that that's interesting
because I was I was listening to last
podcast on the left this morning about
the next serial killer that we're gonna
do on the show who I'm not gonna spoil
it but so I was listening to their
two-part thing about it and they were
talking about a similar thing about they
were wondering if the serial killers
these Psychopaths and everything like
that if they even had any capacity to
look feel a feel an emotion like a
normal person or if anything just had
just had to be opposed but if you watch
it they said they watching the most
amazing things yeah he's at the post
watching this movie is probably kind of
the way
Leonard lake and Charles neighing saw
their crimes right probably something
like this yeah that it wasn't really
serious and I think that's how they they
saw it yeah because it just seems like
kind of fun like yeah and I think even
fun and mechanical yeah these aren't
real people and it's not really
happening and you know it's that kind of
thing I think to even like during while
we were watching the movie I think it
was Chris Jericho that said something
like it with you know at one point I
said it sounds like the Benny Hill music
like oh yeah you know I mean even though
people are getting horribly mutilated
again
yeah the tone is all wrong it's very
straight the tone is all wrong it's I
think they actually try I think they
were trying to make a scary movie they
were trying to make it like a shocking
and it was supposed to be shocking and
part of the thing is that they would
layer in music that was kind of comedic
yeah thinking that it would be more
shocking if you had kind of something
funny over it alright but it doesn't it
just sometimes that works but but not in
this you have to like have a very deft
hand and and sometimes they try to play
some really McCobb spooky [ __ ] but it
didn't come off spooky they didn't
really have synthesizers that it just
didn't it just sounded a very cheap yeah
yeah yeah this movie looked like it
costs about yeah $10 and there's a lot
of humor in it though there is messing
with the cop later on about you about
the heads the cop Jerrica said look like
David Burke oh yeah they kept making
jokes about that like oh and the cop is
[ __ ] making wisecracks you know what
I mean when he's going through the crime
scene seeing all the dead bodies like
yeah yeah making jokes about it yeah
yeah and it's like it was funny because
I guess the I guess the cops name was
Tucci but I kept hearing coochie yeah so
I kept cheese's so I kept calling him
coochie through the whole thing yeah and
that cop they tell you stories about all
these people you know in the movie what
happened to them so I don't want to
steal joe bob's thunder but watch it
it's pretty good saw shudder yeah like I
said they're so [ __ ] many that I have
to watch he did Castle freaky tid
we'll see another one yeah he said we'll
have to like watch I watched the
Heather's one and I watched like a
couple other ones day but I'm like way
behind
but yeah so do you have anything else
you wanted to discuss that on this
Tuesday not really I mean we put up the
bodybuilding show early yeah so
hopefully we're getting a few comments
on it so hopefully everybody's into I
know it's like I said I know it's not
normally what we would do on the show
but I guess we'd Steven Seagal isn't
yeah it's in the same genre as the
Steven Seagal shows in the martial art
shows and those ended up being popular -
yeah so we don't like to show it's
interesting subject there's there's
there's humor in it
- yeah we like whoa it had a lot of fun
but yeah and I found it more interesting
than I expected to you know so
well we'll be back to the horrible trick
I'm next week I promise but yeah so
anyway have a good rest of your Tuesday
and we'll talk to you again tomorrow